I think it's a good thing that like
games that are obviously
pre-arranged that they start to be um
start to be punished so I think Chief
Arbiter and the appeals committee did a
did a good job obviously you know as a
chess player it feels it feels a bit
strange that the tournament is decided
with something that's not happening on
on the chessboard but the important
thing is
that um I think people will think twice
about
um pre-arranging games like that again
and um I mean Daniel had an amazing
performance for him it's a bit of a
shame but um yeah I think that's just um
just the way it is and I I think they
did the right thing